these once close political Partners who
toasted each other's successes perfect
now the relationship anything but
Perfect Two former allies at War
Rishi sunak at a technology event in
London but the focus on his predecessor
around a much awaited parliamentary
report into whether Boris Johnson misled
MPS over partygate and why his allies
didn't get the peerages Mr Johnson
requested Boris Johnson asked me to do
something that I wasn't prepared to do
because I didn't think it was right that
was uh you know either overrule the
holak committee or to make promises with
people now I I wasn't prepared to do
that as I said I didn't think it was
right and if people don't like that then
tough
the PM locking horns with his former
boss over whether he interfered with Mr
Johnson's honors list as he sought to
put distance between the old and new
Tory regimes when I got this job I said
I was going to do things differently
because I wanted to change politics and
that's what I'm doing and I'm also Keen
to make sure that we change how our
country works but getting on with the
job hard when the party's at War within
hours Boris Johnson responding to say
Rishi sunak is talking rubbish to honor
these peerages it was not necessary to
overrule holak that's the commission
which approves peerage appointments but
simply to ask them to renew their
vetting which was a mere formality
Boris Johnson's raging about who of his
allies did or didn't get a place in the
House of Lords but in reality this is a
sideshow the bigger political earthquake
is his announcement that he's quitting
parliament in order to avoid being
potentially suspended by MPS for his
conduct over party gate it's a decision
that has rocked Westminster and now
threatens to plunge the conservatives
into another very public civil war The
Establishment has has seen Boris out the
door I think you know people look at the
facts then they will they will they
either will or won't agree with me that
parliamentary privileges committee
report investigating Mr Johnson over
partygate due in the coming days and
does Mr Johnson seeks to undermine that
inquiry other stressing their decision
must be respected we have to be really
strong about calling out people who are
attacking institutions people who are
attacking the house for carrying out its
uh its work people who are attacking the
media we have to stand up for these
things because the price of not doing so
is is going to be very grave indeed
another political earthquake expected
this week when the committee published
their findings over Boris Johnson's
conduct drama and distraction that an
already struggling Rishi sunak really
doesn't need bath Rigby Sky News in
Westminster